cloud function second gen helps
developers achieve more when deploying
their code to a server-less environment
longer processing times faster response
times with greater cost efficiency and
native integrations with dozens of event
sources features like these enable
developers to take advantage of
serverless with more diverse workloads
i introduced some of this new
functionality embedded into the new
generation of cloud functions but today
let's take a deeper dive into how these
functions and second gen work and walk
through how developers can take
advantage of this functionality
these new features in cloud function
second gen can be categorized into two
key themes
enhanced underlying infrastructure and
greater event integrations based on the
open source spec cloud events all while
maintaining the same developer contract
you're familiar with in cloud functions
write your code deploy it and let the
serverless platform handle the rest
it is worth sharing what powers the
improved infrastructure of this new
generation
2nd gen leverages cloud run under the
hood which is google's container as a
service platform this is where new
second gen functionality such as
concurrency and traffic splitting comes
from
the beauty of it is that you don't have
to build and bring a container image to
cloud function second gen as your ticket
for admission
just to use a new feature set
cloud function second gen maintains the
same developer experience as its
preceding generation just bring your
code and the serverless platform will
handle the rest all right let's now dig
into how these features work starting
with one of the ones we heard developers
ask for the most running functions with
a lot longer execution times
event driven functions can now run an
additional minute compared to the
previous generation and http functions
can run more than six times longer in
second generation
this means that you can now bring more
complex functions that perform more
intensive processing to cloud functions
to demonstrate we'll run this function
using cloud functions python 3.8 runtime
it may not be complex but it'll run for
the maximum timeout it's important to
note that the max timeout is supported
across all language runtimes not just
python
we'll deploy this code as a function
called function timeout
and invoke it
with the function invoked we can see the
logs from our code directly in the cloud
functions console
the function counts down minute by
minute until it returns a 504 once the
timeout has been hit
we can also view execution times for our
long running functions and dashboards
provided by cloud functions
and if we look at how we configure this
max timeout
we can do this by appending the timeout
parameter at deploy time to override the
default timeout of one minute now let's
briefly talk about the greater amount of
resources that are now available to your
functions in second gen
previously you were only able to specify
how much memory you wanted to make
available to your instances up to
roughly eight gigabytes with only up to
two cpus per function instance
now you're able to specify double the
amount of cpus up to four vcpus to
allocate to your function while also
doubling the amount of memory you can
make available up to 16 gigabytes this
can help resource intensive workloads
that need to process large files right
to an in-memory file system or even
perform parallel processing
let's move on to traffic splitting in
second generation cloud functions as a
platform provides for you automatic
traffic splitting between various
revisions of your code with this
functionality you can feel safer rolling
out new versions of your code knowing
second gen can make patterns like canary
deployments or a b testing
straightforward to implement
take this example in the diagram where
we have a new version of our code that
we have deployed
rather than immediately promoting it to
serve all production traffic we can
gradually begin sending traffic to it
using second gen starting with 10
percent
let's simulate this scenario by actually
deploying a simple http function there
may be a case in which we are using
cloud function support for environment
variables to flip a new feature in our
code on or off
but in this example let's just set the
variable version to 1.0.0
to deploy the next version of the code
we supply the new environment variable
value to reflect that we are deploying
version 2.0 once we have both versions
of the code deployed to cloud functions
we can actually see that each revision
we've deployed is being tracked in the
underlying infrastructure cloud run
now that cloud run has shared with us
the unique revision ids for our two
versions of our function
we can now declaratively define how
traffic should flow to each revision
in our case here we want to send 90 of
traffic to the first version and 10 of
traffic to the second version we do so
by providing a single parameter to the
underlying cloud run service backing the
cloud function with those traffic
percentages
once we begin issuing requests to the
functions url we can see that we get a
simple response that shows what version
of the app we are accessing
the majority of our traffic is routed to
version one and a small minority of our
traffic is routed to version two all
configured by simple g cloud commands
speaking of functions handling requests
let's cover one more feature that comes
from the new underlying infrastructure
in second gen concurrency
previously in cloud functions each
instance of your code would handle a
single request
this means that as more requests come in
the more compute time your function uses
in cloud function's second gen however
you're now able to define concurrency
that is having one instance of your code
handle multiple requests at the same
time
let's deploy a simple python 3.8
function once we've deployed this
function we can then utilize the
underlying cloud run functionality and
update that cloud function to handle
more than one concurrent request at a
time which is the default
in this case we'll set this value to 8.
we can then use the hey utility to
demonstrate how cloud functions will
handle concurrency
we'll send eight requests at once from
eight different workers
in our demo our cloud function only
accepts requests from authenticated
users so we will obtain our identity
token to pass in our requests using
gcloud and finally we'll send the
request to the url provided to us by
cloud functions
the code for this function simply sleeps
for 15 seconds you'll see we deploy the
two revisions the more recent with
concurrency at eight and the one before
it with concurrency at one when we hit
the function with concurrency at one we
see one request respond quickly and the
remaining seven take much longer
this is because we only had one warm
instance of our function every other
request required a new instance of our
function to spin up which takes time
however after updating concurrency to 8
we see that all our requests complete
roughly within the expected 15 seconds
this is because we had one warm instance
that could handle all eight requests
simultaneously
this brings up a pattern with which you
can utilize concurrency with
in both first and second generation you
have the ability to define a minimum
number of warm instances that are always
ready to handle requests to your
function
this allows for lower latency responses
from your function since you don't need
to pay the penalty from having your code
start up now pair this with concurrency
because a function instance can handle
more than one request at a time you can
now actually use concurrency combined
with minimum instances this helps you
reduce the amount of min instances you
may need to keep around while still
ensuring that you can serve a certain
amount of requests with lower latency
note that in the example we evaluated
prior all we have to do is add the min
instances parameter when deploying the
cloud function
cloud function second gen can support up
to 1 000 concurrent requests but this
maximum for concurrent requests varies
by language runtime so it's advised that
you review the documentation depending
on what language you want to use with
cloud functions
last but not least let's talk about the
new eventing model in cloud function
second generation
the previous generation of cloud
functions had a smaller set of events
that could trigger your code's execution
and these were fairly limited
if you wanted to trigger your code
outside of this set you typically had to
wire code to publish events to cloud pub
sub
by integrating with event arc we ensure
that every event that triggers your code
adheres to the cloud event specification
and open standard for event data format
this means that your code can
consistently handle events in the same
format regardless of what the source is
with these event arc integrations over
90 plus event sources using cloud audit
logs can now be natively created as
triggers for event driven functions no
custom code that you need to wire
together just to trigger your code with
google cloud events
of course you still can utilize some
custom event sources with pubsub to
trigger your functions in this
demonstration here we are using the
second generation triggers based on
event arc and audit logs to process
bigquery event data every time a query
is run
we'll use a query in bigquery now
this one will roughly query 4.5
terabytes of data and take less than 30
seconds to complete this is a fairly
large query so we might want to use a
cloud function to react to its currents
maybe use something like notify admins
that it ran
with the query finished we can get back
to our cloud function and see that we
are writing out the query information to
standard out but of course we could
extend this to send a message to slack
do some processing or anything else that
we can imagine
bigquery is just one example with cloud
audit logs and event arc we can now
trigger off dozens and dozens of google
cloud events
with all of these new features within
these two themes cloud function second
generation considerably improves the
experience for developers when compared
to its preceding version
but for all of you who have built on top
of the first generation
it's important to note your function in
the first generation will continue to
run as is
over time if you find the features suit
your needs or improve your workflow you
can begin to deploy these functions to
the second generation so
thanks for spending this time digging
into cloud function second gen if you
want to learn more then check out the
documentation and code labs to get
familiar with the improved developer
experience this is stephanie wong see
you next time